unemployment claimants are looking for
help after problems while trying to
verify their identity now it's on a
third party system named
id me joe muller shares the frustration
some
are going through idmi is a third party
website that's being used for pool
acclaim and some have said the best
place to get help is through the idme
website but others say
they're having a hard time getting
through we haven't gotten our
unemployment
for this week or lisa patterson gardner
is worried about missing more benefits
you know they're saying keep all your
verification in your back pocket
and we'll get in touch with you but
you're you may be waiting five
hours because you're in line she says
she uploaded all her personal
information to verify her identity
through id me
but is having trouble getting it
approved and getting through to help
no one ever got in touch with me no more
than ever got in touch with my husband
she isn't the only one having trouble
this is a popular topic on unemployment
facebook groups
it's going to be very busy right now
just like anything else any lender
bank sba irs people are slammed right
now
amber hansen runs one of those pages she
says id me is being used for all pua
claimants right now due to a new law in
a number of states
the interface of that application is not
necessarily user friendly so people are
getting confused about primary and
secondary identification
and the drop down menus for those as
well as like
when people were prompted in email they
were clicking the blue link instead of
the green box
from uploading documents to following
directions closely hanson says if you
have a problem try to seek assistance
through the online help window
she had to verify her identity and
waited around two hours before an
employee got back to her
if you need help you just create a
support ticket
and you get on a referee call my biggest
suggestion is that at the top of their
search bar where you refresh the page
when claimants see the estimated time go
blank
they just need to refresh that page
hanson says the assistant's window can
help take photos and verify information
she says to try at odd hours when the
site is possibly less used
amber says the deter phone operators
most likely won't be able to help with
the id me situations because it is a
third party she says the best bet
to get some help is through the help
ticket on the idme website
reporting outside the detour office joe
mohler 8 news now good information there
well joe also did reach out for
to the id me for information or guidance
but we have not yet
heard back